how much time do I get just go I think
by now we know that I love a sophie
Turner but holy OMG this really takes it
to a whole new level sophie Turner
totally slapped Conan O'Brien on his
show thought it was all part of a
drinking game sophie was actually
teaching him to people stand opposite
one another one person takes a shot and
before they have time to swallow it the
other person slaps him around the face
okay so not a drinking game I've ever
heard of nor one that I would want to
play but that was entertaining a and you
know what else is entertaining this
video of the Jonas Brothers showing us
just how much they miss Sophie's show
Game of Thrones given winter and and
fall which is coming
[Music]
yo Joe what did I say about making Game
of Thrones references in front of Joe
not today thank you Kevin it's not Joe
Kevin won't stop quoting Game of Thrones
when you play the game of Thrones you
win or you die even nick who claims he's
the least affected is well dealing with
it in his own way
so what's the deal with the swords I'm
sorry 100 people see you on set
swashbuckling what the north the guys
also open up about their marriages to
Harper's Bazaar Joe reveals it was
actually a Sophie who helped him fix his
relationships with his brothers quote it
encouraged me to see she has such a
great relationship with her brothers
that was really a big thing for me to be
able to look at and say I got to get my
[ __ ] together et was just with Sophie at
the premiere of Dark Phoenix she talked
about Joe's support what is it like to
have a man you said you brought your
husband to have him sitting beside you
when you're showing the world this move
is great it's wonderful it's it's
nerve-wracking but it's amazing it's a
bit of comfort and otherwise
nerve-racking day all right guys who
takes the cake for best video here
Sophie slapping Conan or the Joe Broz
really missing Game of Thrones let me
know and for all the latest on them keep
it locked to et until next time I'm
Katie Krauss and you next time